[Música]
olá hoje vou falar sobre isso é o melhor
remédio
você chegou a pensar que o dia é uma
forma de aliviar toda a atenção do corpo
e ainda por cima não paga nada a vida
simples você tem um problema sim ele tem
solução sim então não se preocupe você
tem um problema sim ele tem solução não
tão bem nos preocupe eu gosto de sucção
grama pois mostra como às vezes nós
complicamos a vida sendo que a melhor
coisa a se fazer é não se preocupar uma
boa risada alivia a tensão física e
estresse
relaxa os músculos aumento no número de
células emergente cops combate às
infecções melhorar sua resistência às
doenças e shiloh sistema imunológico
[Risadas]
os seus jogos comprovar não quis dizer
contagiante e como nesse exemplo não é
apenas o fato do barulho do papel que o
fez ir mas sim da companhia de seu pai
piso sem parecer o mais importante aqui
pensando e com o médico que mais se
durante as consultas que vocês sabem o
torre no
quando rimos deverão ser antonina que a
nossa antidepressivo natural existe uma
prática chamada riso terapia ela tem a
função de instaurar o contato entre o
adulto e sua criança interior
mas é importante destacar que essa
terapia não é considerado uma terapia
por si só pois não têm a função de curar
uma doença
só que traz vantagens em estande weiss
que esse sim contribuem para um
tratamento médico
vocês conhecem o marcio ballas vou
contar uma breve história sobre ele e
tinha uma vida normal era dono de uma
papelaria até que seu amigo convidou
para fazer parte de um curso de palhaço
e logo aceitou largou tudo pegou suas
economias e foi para paris a por três
anos depois de lá foi para o palhaço sem
fronteiras em uma missão na o banha na
guerra no meio de refugiados
lá e depois de ver e sentir que o
palhaço tempo pode mudar o mundo é
respirar fundo e jogar com isso mudar a
vida de crianças no meio do caos fez
sentir tudo aquilo vale a pena realmente
ser palhaço é um dom
outros exemplos são o doutor pet adams
que o grupo não governamental
hospitalizados
ele tem a função de levar o humor para o
ambiente hospitalar causando risco nos
pacientes
você já parou para pensar que muitas
pessoas acordam cedo para trabalhar e
muitas vezes estava desgastante no sol e
precisam de muitas condições para chegar
até lá
mas mesmo assim leva uma vida com bom
humor como esses trabalhadores
só que existem pessoas que têm um carro
confortável com ar condicionado ligado
escutando música e quando trânsito
você já tentaram se colocar no lugar do
outro e não reclamar tanto eu sei que
nós não conseguimos ser felizes o tempo
todo pois todos temos problemas mas a
melhor canção z é saber lidar com eles
de maneira possível isso tendo a inveja
perdendo o medo da mudança abrirá mão do
controle e diminuindo o excesso de
trabalho e com certeza você será mais
feliz
mas afinal você gestor de hoje
um dia quem sabe um dia jogar fora
segundo o shopping
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]